let's write the train season's greetings
friends this that sleigh bells I hear no
no that's gunfire target spotted the
festive season has arrived in Apex
legends with mirages holiday bash events
from December 12th through January 7th
you can play the new limited time game
mode winter Express experience the new
town take over the Mirage voyage and
unlock a whole bunch of cosmetic gifts
so let's dive straight in with
everything you need to know
welcome to mirages winter Express this
holiday season you are cordially invited
to the Outlands biggest holiday
celebration alkyd power mirage is
introducing his town take over and will
be bringing his party ship the Mirage
voyage moored up for the winter between
thermal station and lava fissure on
world's edge the vessel comes complete
with Christmas trees tinsel and festive
lights for that real holiday feel like
any good party attendance is always
expected to be high and all the best
presents are there for early arrivals
fashionably late will only lead to
disappointment here that's right the
town takeover features the biggest ship
we've seen so far in apex legends and
has completely swamped the town below in
snow the almost two stories high you'll
easily spot the Mirage voyage as you fly
in thanks to the insane amount of
fireworks going off all around it once
you land you can literally get the party
started by hitting the button on the
high deck towards the back of the ship
the first player to do so will be
rewarded with two Lupin shooting out
from below deck though careful they
don't get snatched up before you you'll
also be treated to some enormous Mirage
projections grooving out to the music
all over the ship the first time you hit
the button you'll also unlock the event
exclusive legendary g7 Scout skin oh you
can keep hitting the party button -
there's no more bonus loot but who
doesn't love a 50-foot Mirage doing the
worm on top of the ship speaking of
Mirage you'll find an entire troop of
them hanging out in the hot tub and on
the dance floor now if you're the kind
of person who prefers to find themselves
on the naughty list each year why not
switch your Mirage character outfit back
to defaults and join the get-together
hiding in plain sight might just be the
trick to pulling a strategic bamboozle
on an unsuspecting enemy if the party
still feels lacking pop your ultimate
and turn that plus 1 into a plus 6 now
that's a whole lot of handsome there's
something else hiding in plain sight on
the dance floor - that disco ball
hanging above the bar is more than just
disco decoration wait for the color to
change from blue to gold and put some
rounds into it for that extra little bit
of holiday gifting the spirit of
generosity is all over the ship from the
loot underneath the Christmas trees to
Mirage helping himself live out his
Titanic fantasies at the bow of the ship
it feels like my heart will go on oh oh
wait no it doesn't
- dude all aboard the winter Express any
passengers not in possession of a valid
ticket will be shot yes the main
attraction to Mirage is holiday bash is
the limited time game-mode or winter
Express here we have three teams of
three dropping onto the newly
refurbished Holiday Train as it goes
from station to station the objective is
to capture the train by getting a team
member on board and holding it without
getting killed the first team to capture
the winter Express three times is
declared the champion simple enough but
things have been shaken up quite a bit
more than just that starting from the
legend select screen you'll see that
each legend comes with a predetermined
loadout including attachments ammunition
and armor this is because there's no
need to loot in winter Express save
yourself that first game embarrassment
of running off into the nearest building
only to realize it's completely empty
trust me instead you'll want to look out
for the small yellow triangle on the map
as you're dropping in which will let you
know where the first station stop is
going to be plus the loadout for each
legend is changed daily so once set up
the work for you before may be
completely different the next day and
your favorite weapons may well be on a
legend that you don't normally play as
part of your preset loadout it appears
you only have one syringe and one shield
cell in a loop this game is not much
surely well fret not these are unlimited
and you can heal as many times as you
need actually do fret a bit because
there's also no knockdowns in winter
Express if you get shot to bits as
you're trying to board the winter
Express you can expect to be out for the
remainder of the round fortunately this
is not wasted time for you as once
eliminated you'll be able to select a
different legend for the next round if
you felt that loadout or strategy wasn't
working for you you'll also get a
complete ammo refill - as you drop back
in which is handy as the only ammo drops
come from player eliminations - boxes
are dropped by each full and player with
the ammo type matching the weapon that
they were killed by but capturing the
Train is no simple feat it takes 10
seconds for the objective to unlock
after the Express pulls into the stage
and then you've only got one minute to
capture the train by boarding it at
endpoints if you see an enemy team
rushing the capture you'll need to board
the train yourself to make that capture
contested pausing their progress if
after one minute the train is still
contested you'll go into overtime for 30
seconds here the train can still be
captured but only from the center car
it's almost completely exposed so choose
your moment wisely if there's still no
decisive winner then it's time for the
train to depart to the next station
closing the objective until it's stopped
again if you've successfully captured
the winter Express well done
your point is noted in the top right and
any fallen allies will be immediately
respawn as you journey to the next
station the challenging teams meanwhile
will have to wait and reselect legends
before dropping in again for the next
round if you don't fancy defending the
train as the round victors you can
always jump off at any point on the
tracks and hit one of the new jump pads
now these are fully amped up jump pads
taking you all the way to the spawn
height and allowing you to drop in any
way you like
speaking of strategy try experimenting
with rushing the objective versus
waiting to third-party if you hang back
you may find you have time to swap
around attachments and weapons between
your teammates got a digital threat
scope on that Mozambique it may be more
effective on your friends are 99 plus
the abilities of the characters can be
extra useful in different situations
caustic and Watson can fill the Train
with traps even while it's moving while
lifeline can call in some purple armor
in a loot drop if you're lucky
now what are the most exciting parts of
any limited time event is getting
exclusive cosmetics as with previous
events there are 12 epic and 12
legendary collectibles which can be
unlocked with premium event loot packs
apex coins and crafting metals there are
also earnable cosmetics from in-game
challenges including two legendary gun
skins for the g7 Scouts and L star but
even more exciting still is that by
unlocking the full 24 sec collection you
automatically unlock the next heirloom
set in the apex series this time for
Pathfinder joining the ranks of Wraith
bloodhound and lifeline Pathfinder gets
a custom voice line banner pose and its
very own set of boxing gloves complete
with him oats that pesky Raven that
keeps harassing him is finally getting
his holiday gift a swift punch to the
entire body and that's just about
everything you need to know about the
Rogers holiday bash have you found any
awesome strategies that guarantee a
train capture and have you successfully
bamboozled the enemy playing his Mirage
on his ship in casual or ranked play let
us know how you get on you'll find all
the latest on apex legends over at
GameSpot calm and remember friends happy
holidays no watchin watching get into IV
let's take it at Melfi no y-you look at
me that way
you
[Music]